les attentes étaient élevées les
conditions météo idéales et au départ le
décollage de Starship la fusée géante de
SpaceX s'est déroulée parfaitement sous
un tonnerre d'applaudissements
mais 4 minutes plus tard le spectacle
s'est transformé en feu d'artifice sur
Twitter le grand patron et la Mosk a
réagi aujourd'hui on a appris beaucoup
de choses qui seront utiles pour le
prochain test dans quelques mois
il faut dire que chez SpaceX faire
exploser des fusées c'est devenu une
habitude la stratégie on prend de gros
risques et on tire des leçons de ses
erreurs on a réussi à faire décoller la
fusée on a réussi à tester les moteurs
en haut de décollage et en vol et on a
réussi à récolter plein de données qui
vont nous permettre de progresser et
puis c'est le propre de la science là de
faire des essais erreurs c'est important
rappelons que la fusée Starship est un
véritable monstre 120 mètres de hauteur
plus de puissance que toutes les fusées
jamais conçues et en théorie la capacité
de recevoir jusqu'en centaine de
passagers et tout ça avec du matériel
complètement réutilisable c'est
quasiment trois fois la puissance du
plus puissant lanceur actuel qui est le
LCS avec le programme Artemis donc
vraiment là on a affaire une fusée
absolument incroyable et il faut
maîtriser cette puissance là c'est ça
qui est difficile en fait
un moyen terme le projet d'Elon mask qui
bénéficie maintenant du soutien
financier de la NASA et d'utiliser sa
nouvelle fusée pour la reconquête et la
colonisation de la lune puis
ultimement celle de la planète Mars si
les couronnés de succès le projet
Starship aurait un grand impact sur
toutes l'industrie spatiale
s'utilise un mélange de carburant très
polluant qui équivaut pour un seul
lancement aux émissions de CO2 de près
d'un millier de vols Montréal Paris ici
normand Grondin Radio-Canada Montréal